we are joined by the respect MP George
Galloway MP a course now for Bradford
but scottish-born and you're no friend
of the Tory government it has to be said
and yet you don't sympathize with the
argument the Scotland hasn't voted for a
Tory government for a long time so
perhaps it's time to go at Sian and vote
for its own government well there are
plenty of Tories in Scotland of course
four hundred and sixteen thousand people
voted for them just a couple of months
ago and another hundred thousand voted
for UK so we shouldn't imagine Scotland
is a Cuba just waiting to be unleashed
but they sympathize with the new voters
who were just interviewed in your
package the sight of Lord snooty and his
top hat coming over the border is enough
to stir your adviser notes go indeed the
coalition government is the principal
reason why we're looking down the barrel
of the breakup of the country and Tony
Blair's government is an additional
secondary reason why do you care and why
do you care about the Union
well Bradford will be in a desperate
state if the country breaks up because
take 49 non Tory MPs out of Westminster
and Ed Miliband will struggle to win any
election in those circumstances and the
prospect for much of England of Tory
government into the foreseeable future
maybe into perpetuity is a disaster for
working people on this side of the
border but most importantly as a Scot I
don't want to see Scotland commit a
significant act of self harm you quoted
me earlier saying havoc would ensue it's
already begun Alex Salmond is coming
business man's fears this evening before
the votes even been held never mind
independence declared and the billions
that were wiped off the share price of
Scottish based companies yesterday and
the slide and the pound is only the
beginning here he says keep the power
and keep the Queen keep the social Union
so this would only be really a political
adjustment no because he
to keep the pound and shouldn't keep the
pound if Scotland became independent the
worst thing in the world would be to use
another country's currency that makes
you a colony like Panama it would be
absurd to see you were independent
whilst being dependent on economic
fiscal monetary decisions made in a
London parliament in which you had no
members
what's your answer if you or your
children are faced with the choice where
either you can be Scottish or you can be
I suppose British or lesser British well
I think we don't want to have to make
that choice we can have the best of both
worlds the Gordon Brown's package that
he unveiled yesterday gives super Devo I
mean never mind Devo max this is a super
level of devolution why throw that away
if you can have that and the additional
strength security and weight by being
part of a bigger country I mean there is
this feeling sometimes in England
sometimes expressed particularly by
conservatives that I mean one person
summed up said well Gordon Brown's
speech amounts to saying vote for the
Union so the rest of England can go on
paying for Scotland's pensions and
welfare I don't think that's true we've
lived together for 300 years there have
been times when England had more
economic contribution times when
Scotland since 1974 the oil and so on
it's 50/50 that who's paying for whom
I'm more interested in the fact that
mortgages will go up that they'll be a
race to the bottom as a center-right
government in Scotland and a right-wing
government in England cut tax and
regulation and public expenditure to be
more and more Thatcherite more and more
attractive to big business to come in
the working people are sure to lose that
race and you feel about this emotionally
I mean for years they'd like a divorce
yes and you know and I've been divorced
it's never Pleasant you can argue about
the CDs the DVDs the dog the car maybe
even the house but the one thing that
never ever happens
is that the person walking out the door
when you're begging them to stay gets to
continue to use the joint family credit
card and that's essentially what Alex
Hammond has in mind you been in Scotland
obviously been involved in the campaign
what do you think is gonna happen well I
think is very close as Alex Ferguson a
great Scot and a great no voter would
put it it's squeaky bum time and those
bums are definitely squeaking on the
train to Edinburgh tomorrow George
Galloway thanks IRA Thanks